nous avons l'intention en a parlé avec
marielle herbert de faire une séance non
pas d'une heure mais de deux heures une
fois par mois sur les questions
européennes qui sera précisément
précisément axée sur la sur les
problématiques européennes avec non pas
un mais probablement deux intervenants
quand ça sera deux heures
mais pour les autres et pour prendre
l'habitude notre intention était de
faire ça une fois par semaine en dehors
des vacances évidemment donc les
vacances de la toussaint les vacances de
noël les vacances de printemps les
vacances de pâques tout ça fait que que
c'est une fois par semaine mais pas
toute l'année évidemment si vous voulez
bien je propose qu'on essaie sachant que
toutes ces rencontres sont naturellement
publié sur internet qu'on peut y avoir
accès et que un jour quand on sera riche
c'est à dire quand les poules auront des
dents on va le faire en direct ça coûte
un peu plus cher pour que des
intervenants puissent se joindre à notre
this discussion
j'ajoute puisqu'on est sur internet au
moment tout cas où nos amis de province
regarderons ça qu'on envisage aussi d'en
proposer pour des réunions en province
que ça ne soit pas uniquement
paris mais vous voyez que ça demande une
logistique un peu plus importante et je
propose donc on rôde
ces conférences dans un premier temps
sous cette forme
naturellement elles seront transcrites
par écrit peut-être pas celle de pisany
ferry ce soir mais elles seront
transcrites pas écrit de manière qu'on
puisse aussi avoir avoir un accès à ces
échanges d'idées
donc vous êtes naturellement tout à fait
libre est tout à fait bienvenu de nous
proposer des sujets et des personnalités
que vous souhaiteriez voir c'est une
chance que nous ayons cette salle cet
équipement et viennent volontiers les
gens qui réfléchissent et les
conférenciers parce que on a la
réputation qu'ici c'est de bonne foi et
donc c'est très vous êtes parfaitement
libre de suggéré de demander de nous
inviter à prendre contact avec quelqu'un
que vous avez entendu que qui vous
paraît bien intéressant tous les
problèmes sont naturellement ouvert
d'accord bon et bien on va mettre tous
nos rangs ouvrir la discussion
tout est ouvert on va faire un peu
d'économies un peu de politique un peu
de autant que vous le voudrez ces jeunes
gens qui filme la sont les bienvenus
mais c'est pas pour une émission
d'actualité c'est pour une émission qui
lui à faire des images de réflexion donc
vous ne diffuserait pas sans notre
accord
donc pour que pour que tout le monde
puisse s'exprimer librement
d'accord jean-pierre vous voulez
commander
dire un mot parce que je pense qu'il ya
d'abord de la ressource frappé par la
qualité de ses de ces réunions du samedi
dont je me souvienne au cours de la
campagne présidentielle bat aux
quantités des germes est en commission
étaient apportées évidemment la déjà un
certain nombre de fidèles il y à tous
ceux que vous prêt à discuter avec nous
de quoi de tout et de rien mais me de
sujets d'actualité politique qui vous
intéresse nous mouvement démocrate et
sur lesquels nous voudrions tenté
d'avoir quelques vues pertinentes et
originales
il ya tout l'apport jeudi saint à prix
modestement delà de l'université
populaire qui est évidemment mises à
contribution dans tout cela et qui
apporte force il ya il y a il ya peu
plus il y à tous de tous ceux qui nous
ont fait l'honneur et l'amitié de venir
acquis tels qu'en commencé à déballer
leurs leur leurs peurs leurs petites
affaires
je pense que donc le
je dirais essayer de trouver des
intervenants notoire qui sont capables
de nous expliciter de manière originale
et un autre je dirais pour notre corps
notre profit politique un certain nombre
de grandes questions
alors reste à définir les grandes
questions moi je résoudrai plutôt non
pas en semaine ni en moi mais plutôt sur
le vu le nombre de sujets sur lesquels
nous voulons réfléchir le plus
intelligemment possible alors qu'ils
sont dans l'année alors qu'il est
aujourd'hui et dans l'est dans les mois
qui viennent alors nous avec eux avec
agnès louis bayrou nous avons un peu
dans la lancée d'une université
populaire réfléchit à des sujets que
nous mettons bien volontiers dans la
corbeille
je peux peut-être les énumérer en l'état
nous nous en sommes là je pense qu'il y
aura une réflexion à conduire et nous
avons vous appelez le françois et nous
avons tous en tête le nom michèle cotta
oui michèle cotta sera la prochaine à
orthez le et les dates ne sont pas faits
dans ces cent en décembre les mesures
mais sans succès c'est désormais s'est
fixée s'est fixé donc sur sur médias
il n'y a pas de photos envoyées
j'y viens
/
non rassure médias et démocratie elle
peut viser une des alignements des dates
et d'insulter un du 18 décembre
démocratie et médias si on peut on
commencera le rythme régulier des
rencontres hebdomadaires le mardi
précédant le 18 décembre ont hanté
précédent donc peut-être dans deux
semaines et en tout cas michèle cotta
est fixée le 18 autres sujets il y
actuellement une réflexion en cours dans
d'autres sociologique dans une texture
ou d'économie et de gestion municipale
ce qu'est ce que c'est que les
l'écartèlement des grandes et et
métropoles urbaines et sva entre disons
le global et le local qu'est ce que
c'est que la nouvelle gestion que nous
impose que nous impose le nouveau siècle
là je pense qu olivier mongin qui
devrait venir acquis tels d'ailleurs
olivier mongin de la revue esprit de la
revue esprit qui nous expliquera sa très
bien ex-taulard vela sujet qui le
passionne
nous avions et françois pays au premier
chef cochet pendant la campagne
électorale au juste ap la campagne n'est
ce pas le
à pied de gérard grumberg sur au fond le
le bipartisme en dot ou voir en
déconfiture n'ose pas y aller il y en a
à ce sujet pour nous et est tout à fait
cardinal il faudra faire les
explorations internationale ça va de soi
je crois savoir que françois bayrou
prend la route de la chine quelque part
au printemps prochain donc là il faudra
bien qu'ils avec quelques experts et
notamment notre avis jean-luc d'honneur
françois godement ils viennent nous
expliquer un peu haut ce qu'elle son
retour de chine avec quelque elle
profite quantité d'autres sujets pour
nous cardinal en termes européen qu'est
ce qu'il faut penser d'une modélisation
possible de l'action de mario monti en
italie il ya là un sujet souvent souvent
évoqué la sympa très difficile de
trouver qui vaudra nous nous nous aider
nous avons surveillé y être très grand
assaut pas seulement de publications me
mettais travaux sur cette espèce de
fractures à la fois géographique et
social qui est en train
d'affaiblir et de recomposer ce ou de
décomposer ce pays le thème de la france
en miettes n'est ce pas sous sous
l'assaut combiné de fracture
géographique et sociale voilà quelque
chose qu'un qu'un grand sociologue comme
jean pierre le goff abondamment
abondamment évoqués et qui pourra venir
ne nous expliquer je signale à ceux qui
sont debout au fond de la salle qu'il
reste 4 5 6 7 8 9 place au premier rang
dans les premiers rangs première on peut
y aller et venez soyez pas timides
installez-vous je crois qu'on pourrait
aussi s'intéresser de près à ce que
pourrait être éventuellement une
philosophie du développement durable
n'est ce pas incantations sur ce mot
mais elle sent je dirais les occasions
philosophico politique ou en philosophie
politique assez assez argumenté il se
trouve que là il va y avoir des
publications je pense que sur la
question des femmes et nous pensons la
sylviane agacinsky bien sûr
une séance sur et vous savez que c'est
ça c'est sa thèse et sa proposition les
femmes entre sexe et genre n'est ce pas
et avec toutes les conséquences que cela
peut avoir sur certains de nos débats de
société
aujourd'hui nicole notât pourrait
peut-être venir nous expliquer quelque
chose qui compte que moi je connais mal
mais qui dit qui arrive à peu près
partout dans la gestion des entreprises
dans la gestion des collectivités qui
s'appelle la notation sociale
comment et pourquoi il ya t'il cents
ce développement là on peut trouver
quantité d'autres sujets moi à mon sens
dans cette première exploitation je
pense que nous avons de manière utile
pour les jusqu'à pour l'année la rentrée
de septembre 2013 nous avons eu une
bonne dizaine voire une douzaine de
sujets explorés
ils sont donc urgence politique me
semble aussi absolu pour le mode pour le
modèle à tous les concours sont les
bienvenus vous pouvez le faire des
propositions et de thèmes et de deux
personnalités riz de personnalités en
l'état dans nous en train de de
configurer tout ça mais leur escale sur
tous ces sujets là ça vous paraît
intéressant important
oui ça l'est nutile enfin je voudrais
vous suggérer de vous faire accompagner
par des amis des proches que vous seriez
intéressé même s'ils ne sont pas
militants parce que notre vocation c'est
d'être précisément un lieu où on
réfléchit à la politique où on en fait
mais on n'en fait pas sans avoir
réfléchi au préalable ce qui est avouons
le une curiosité dans le paysage
politique actuel
c'est très c'est très important je vous
dire ce que je crois oui on va ainsi
lancer le débat sur la situation au pays
ce soir on annonce 50 mille chômeurs de
plus encore et si on compte les chômeurs
à temps incomplet si j'ose dire on est à
75 mille de plus en un seul mois
73 milles
oui la progression ces quarante cinq
mille cinq cents ce qui veut dire que on
est à 3 million cent mille chômeurs qui
sont totalement sans activité si on
ajoute outre-mer on est à 3 millions 350
me si on ajoute ceux qui sont sans
activité avec une activité partielle et
qui recherchent un emploi
on est à quatre millions neuf cent mille
chômeurs et si on veut dire est ce si on
intègre ceux qui sont par ailleurs
dispensés de recherche d'emploi on
arrive à 5 million deux cent mille cinq
millions de zambiens france c'est pas
comment dire deux ou trois pays ces cinq
millions deux cents ans les je vous
signale ce que j'avais dit à françois il
ya quelques jours je vous signale que
contrairement à ce qu'on dit parfois
dans l'actualité
l'augmentation actuelle du chômage n'est
pas une augmentation qui réunit des
plans sociaux qui n'ont pu se produire
après l'élection présidentielle parce
qu'il faut savoir que quand il ya des
plans sociaux
la plupart du temps l'immense majorité
des salariés ne pointe pas à pôle emploi
pendant un an puisqu'ils bénéficient de
convention qui font qu'ils ont un
maintien du salaire et donc on ne les
voit arriver dans les chiffres du
chômage pour l'essentiel quinze ans
après autrement dit la progression
actuelle du chômage n'est pas liée aux
plans sociaux de la praye élections
présidentielles et deux chiffres
simplement pour vous
montrez l'aggravation et la gravité des
choses les moins de 25 ans donc en un an
donc si on est à 9,7 pour cent
d'augmentation du chômage chez les moins
de 25 ans mais ces chômeurs de longue
durée
on est à + 11 1% en un an donc en gros
pour faire simple
nos chemins les chômeurs de longue durée
et les moins de 25 ans c'est une
progression de 10% comment dire en un an
un million neuf cent mille chômeurs de
longue durée
les chiffres bruts je trouve donne un
éclairage qui extraordinairement
l'impressionnant impressionnant qui
donne toute la mesure du défi que nous à
nous comme mouvement politique mais nous
france avons devant et moi ce qui me
frappe et je suis sûr que ça vous frappe
aussi à avoir suivi l'actualité toute
cette dernière semaine
c'est l'incroyable distance qu'il ya
entre les préoccupations les
affrontements les querelles les
rivalités du monde politique et la
situation réelle du pays avec 2 pour moi
deux interrogations ou deux réflexions
extraordinairement préoccupante
premièrement tout à l'heure jean pierre
disait la société explose le les
familles les repères les religions voilà
l aidant dans un mécanisme de deux
d'explosion continue d' éloignement
progressif des éléments les uns par
rapport aux autres mais la société
politique aussi c'est la même explosion
qui est dans le monde politique
et alors ça a été évidemment
spectaculaire toute cette dernière
semaine à l'ump parce que la guerre à
l'ump ça n'est évidemment pas seulement
une guerre de personnes c'est une guerre
de ligne politique c'est l'affrontement
entre deux lignes politiques ce qui dans
la lignée de la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy c'est à dire dans la lignée de
ce qu'on appelle la pensée buisson ont
choisi d'aller chercher leur succès
électoral du côté de l'extrême droite
c'est à dire d'exciter les gens les uns
contre les autres les passions de
rechercher les antagonismes pour faire
leur succès électoral j'ouvre ici une
parenthèse
moi je pense que ça marche tu pas en
train de dire que cette stratégie est
une stratégie qui n'apporte pas des voix
ça apporte beaucoup de voix hélas je
pense qu'ils se sont ils ont compris
très tôt buisson et ceux qui l'écoutent
ont compris très tôt que
hélas les passions en politique sont
plus forte que la raison et les passions
noir négative d'agressivité de
détestation sont plus fortes que les
passions positive notre notre maître
marc sangnier disait l'amour est plus
fort que la haine on se marie tu as
peut-être qu'ils disent est ce enfin
l'un ou l'autre bon électoralement ça
discute du point de vue des fins
dernière du point de vue de l'évolution
de l'humanité je crois que c'est vrai je
crois que l'amour est plus créatif le
les sentiments de compréhension la
volonté de bien faire
la volonté de servir l'idée de progrès
tous à les relier naturellement c'est
plus fort que la détestation mais
électoralement la détestation est un
moteur puissant simplement pour moi un
homme d'état femme boit ça ne peut pas
rechercher le succès électoral
à ce prix là parce que le pays dont vous
avez la charge
la communauté de citoyens dont vous avez
la charge
cette communauté là elle ne peut pas
survivre à l'excitation de la
détestation entre les siens et donc être
un homme d'état c'est précisément
refuser ces facilités pour choisir au
contraire une autre vision de l'avenir
une autre manière de voir les choses une
autre manière de de rendre les gens
compréhensive les envers les autres
lieux de les rendre antagonistes les uns
avec les autres et unis les uns avec les
autres lui de les rampes divisé des uns
avec les autres
donc je ferme cette parenthèse c'est
très fort mais on reconnaît un homme
d'état à ce qu'il refuse
ces facilités dont il connaît la
puissance mais il refuse
donc ça c'est une ligne de ce tout ceux
qui sont à l'extérieur il reste quelques
places sur les banques est là venez les
occuper dans les quoi il reste trois ou
quatre places
ne restez pas à l'extérieur la maison
est à vous voilà et donc ça c'est la
première ligne il ya une deuxième ligne
que moi je considère comme c'est la
ligne que jean françois copé pour
simplifier a choisi avec la puissance
d'engagement de patrick buisson
il ya une deuxième ligne que moi je
considère comme plus intéressante que je
dois dire françois fillon a exprimé
courageusement quand il a dit dans la
dernière semaine en particulier
notre enjeu c'est de rassembler la
droite le centre et même at il d une
partie de la gauche
j'ai trouvé que c'était très courageux
je parle pas d'héroïsme mais je trouve
que exprimé dans une compétition interne
à l'intérieur d'un parti dont on a
vérifié une fois de plus que la loi de
bayrou commentait la vie vous savez la
loi de barros et les partis se tiennent
par leur noyau dur ça s'est vérifié une
fois de plus dans cette affaire j'espère
qu'au bout du compte ça sera pas le cas
mais et donc j'ai trouvé que c'était
courageux et même d'une certaine manière
désintéressée
c'est pas que les uns et tous les vices
et les autres toutes les vertus sais pas
ce que je dis mais en tout cas je
reconnais dans ce débat une partie du
grand enjeu national que nous avons en
face de nous parce que le grand enjeu
national c'est bien ça car lorsque je
regarde ce qui est en train de se
produire à gauche alors je vois la même
explosion en cours
sous nos yeux elle est moins
spectaculaire depuis huit jours parce
que l'ump a fourni un formidable
paratonnerre aux inquiétudes et aux
incertitudes et aux incohérences de la
majorité ou au pouvoir ils ont quand
même rendu le plus extraordinaire des
services qu'on puisse rendre à ceux qui
gouvernent aujourd'hui
depuis dix jours attiré toute
l'attention et ne montrer que c'est
mauvais côté c'est quand même formidable
non c'est comme ça c'est bon et ça
arrive
il ya dans les espèces vivantes des
moments comme ça qui sont des moments de
suicide collectif et c'est très
difficile de les éviter nous en avons
rencontré aussi libre et donc à gauche
explosion explosion entre quoi et coiro
c'est très simple il ya trois explosions
à mes yeux
la première de ces explosions c'est la
fracture entre la gauche de la gauche
les écologistes pour une très grande
partie d'entre eux le front de gauche
est la thèse que françois hollande a
défendu et je les approuve et de l'avoir
fait dans sa conférence de presse qui
est une thèse de recentrage de sa
politique
nécessaire j'ai même dit que c'était ça
pouvait être un bad godesberg à la
française c'est à dire qu en direct il
leur a dit à peu près le contraire de ce
qu'il avait dit pendant la campagne
présidentielle
cette fracture là je ne sais pas où la
ligne de fracture passera exactement
mais je puis dire qu'à mon avis elle
passera en tout cas à l'intérieur du ps
ce qui a aussi à l'intérieur du ps une
partie de sensibilité la première
fracture deuxième fracture
c'est la facture la fracture entre le
projet que les français avaient entendu
pendant la campagne présidentielle et la
politique qui va être mise en place car
sarkozy d'ailleurs aussi comme hollande
avait dit aux français pendant la
campagne ce qui leur ferait plaisir
ce dont il croyait que ça leur ferait
plaisir ce qu' ils croyaient que leurs
électeurs attendaient et donc on leur a
promis la lune des postes des crédits d
allocation d avantage dès la fin des
efforts
sarkozy a dit la crise financière est
finie et les économies c'est fini bon et
d'ailleurs je ferai pas d'impôts alors
quand vous mettez ces trois choses
ensemble vous avez la dimension de de la
déception qui serait intervenu et
françois hollande alors évidemment a
choisi
d'accumuler les promesses positive les
français ont entendu ça dans un
programme en lit pas les lignes on lit
pas les mails et les 110 propositions
pour mitterrand l'heure où les showrooms
il en avait 60 propositions françois
hollande on en tort on on lit pas le
détail des choses on lit on entend le la
musique fredonnées par une campagne et
la musique fredonnées par françois
hollande cédait élisez moi et comme nous
sommes vraiment mieux que ceux qui sont
en place
alors vous allez de nouveau retrouvé les
facilités qui étaient les vôtres
autrefois qu'il a dit ça conan donc et
les 60000 postes dans l'éducation c'est
ça que ça voulait dire et l'augmentation
de 30% de l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire c'est ça que ça voulait dire et
la retraite à 60 ans savait pas très
bien dans quelle condition ni pour qui
c'est ça que ça voulait dire et je
pourrais multiplier ainsi les les
exemples très très nombreux qui allaient
dans ce sens là or évidemment bien qu'on
n'en ait pas aujourd'hui sous les yeux
le détail les mesures qui vont devoir
décider avant les exactement à linverse
on ses promesses parce que si je compte
bien mais robert me dira
on a promis 20 milliards d'économies
cette année moi je veux rappeler que
quand la majorité précédente a voulu
faire un très grand effort d'économie
d'ailleurs avec un certain nombre de
bêtises comme les plus-values sur les
biens immobiliers qui ne s'arrêtait plus
au bout de 15 années mais au bout de
trente années ce qui a bloqué le marché
immobilier absolument partout quand ils
ont fait tous ces efforts là ils ont
économisé 2 milliards là c'est 20 en une
année + 30 sur les trois années
suivantes que ça le ça le deal 40 même
20 + 10 10 10
bon donc ça va être ça ça va être un
décalage très c'est par rapport à ce qui
aurait été c'est à dire c'est pas des
vrais milliards d'économies le ben oui
mais en a fort par rapport à l'hypothèse
de croissance
je dis pas je ne dis pas que ça je dis
pas que je change le magazine ça change
pas le raisonnement mais j'en dirai un
mot tout à l'heure il ya toujours de
chez socialiste dans la présentation
depuis quelques mois les astuces de
présentation quand même qu'il faut
savoir voir et bien selon moi
selon moi dans la démocratie du 21e
siècle
l'astuce est une faiblesse moi j'ai des
idées
j'ai des souvenirs très lointain quand
mitterrand était président de la
république il avait auprès de lui
conseiller en communication qui
s'appelait jacques pilet et qui
d'ailleurs est passé avec chirac après
les puis le pauvre il est mort parce
qu'il était malade et jacques pilant
m'avait en amitié en sympathie
et mitterrand se servaient de jacques
pilhan pour m'envoyer des messages
d'ailleurs d'encouragement général même
quand il était en train de me mettre des
bâtons dans les roues étaient assez
mitterrand bien est-ce parce que d'un
côté je te sabre de l'autre je te fais
savoir que je pense beaucoup de bien de
toi
enfin j'ai écrit sur sûr ça autrefois et
un jours pile ans est venu me voir et
m'a dit tu veux que je te donne un
conseil vraiment précieux et qui te
coûtera rien j'ai dit oui on m'a dit je
vais te dire tu as faiblesse il ya
longtemps vous allez voir que je les ai
perdus depuis longtemps cette faiblesse
là m'a dit habile trop habile et je suis
absolument persuadé que l'habileté
manoeuvrière et dans la conduite des
peuples en surtout en temps de crise est
une faiblesse est une erreur ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut être stupide
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il est recommandé
d'être maladroit mais vous comprenez
faut dire la vérité aux gens en tout cas
moi je suis absolument persuadé de ça
c'est la vérité qui est à la base du
contrat démocratique et si on ne le fait
pas on se casse la figure parce que la
perte de confiance est mortelle ça c'est
la deuxième fracture et la troisième
facture qui découle de celle là c'est
que françois hollande n'a pas la
majorité du projet qu'il doit soutenir
sa majorité
enfin de l'action qu'il va mener sa
majorité de celles du projet qu'il avait
présenté aux français ou que les
français avaient entendu ou qu'il
s'était arrangé pour que les français
entendent et ses trois fractures là
elles vont être naturellement très
lourde alors fracturé à gauche fracturé
à droite et alors je vous livre le fond
de ce que je pense il est impossible de
sortir le pays des difficultés qui sont
les siennes en ayant au pouvoir qu une
minorité fragile que qu'une majorité
divisée
avec en face une opposition systématique
le fait qu'ils soient contre que
l'opposition soit pas définition contre
avant qu'on sache ce qu'ils vont dire ou
décider mais ils sont contre considère
toujours que ça va pas c'est pas assez
ou que c'est le contraire qu'il fallait
faire vous souvenez ce ce président
américain qui avait une pancarte devant
lui qui disait la réponse est non et
maintenant dites moi quelle est la
question est bien le latitude le
l'espèce de systématisme dans
l'opposition qui est la marque de la
politique française qui était l'attitude
des socialistes hier et qui est
l'attitude de l'ump est d'ailleurs de
lui dit aujourd'hui ils disent non mais
ça va pas ils disent les bras m'en
tombent
je suis estomaqué j'arrive pas à
comprendre comment on a joué assez jeu
autrefois mais en temps de crise vous
pouvez pas vous payer ces jeux les
décisions vont être si difficile à
assumer qu'on aurait besoin que les
grands courants démocratiques du pays
disent écoutez sur ces trois ou quatre
choses
nous allons nous soutenir nous allons
nous souder et c'est pour moi la clé la
seule clé du redressement du pays si on
n'arrive pas à ça alors vous allez voir
que la prochaine élection sera encore
une alternance dans l'autre sens et
déception sur des illusions au bout du
compte je vais vous dire qui va gagner
c'est les extraits et notamment
l'extrême droite
parce que parti comme on est on est en
train de créer les conditions pour une
vague d'extrême droite désastreuses pour
l'avenir du pays
désastreuse qui nous conduira à des
catastrophes
mais je crains que si on continue comme
ça s'il n'y a pas une revendication
civique de gens qui disent écoutez nous
nous ne sacrifions rien de nos opinions
mais nous sommes là pour aider à sortir
le pays des difficultés
et voilà notre vocation à nous notre
travail et nous notre job à nous voilà
pourquoi nous sommes singulier
différents dans la politique française
et voilà pourquoi nous avons une mission
qui ne peut être assumée par personne
d'autre c'est très difficile c'est très
exigeant
je vous dis pas que ça soit confortable
ça ne l'est pas ça n'enrichit pas je
profite au passage pour vous dire qu'on
est pauvre donc on va vous faire une
petite lettre pour voir si par hasard
vous ne pourriez pas bon mais on est
libre on et non-alignés
ce qui veut dire qu'on peut approuver
fortement quand ça va dans le bon sens
et combattre fortement quand ça va dans
le mauvais sens j'étais ce matin sur rtl
j'ai expliqué que à mon avis moi qui
avait soutenu les propos de hollande
dans sa conférence de presse la manière
dont hot bourg conduisait le combat sur
la sphère mittal était contre productive
pour le pays telles contraire en aller
dans le mauvais sens parce que quand
vous tend les investisseurs c'est un
petit monde les investisseurs du monde
en temps de dire nous ne voulons plus de
mittal en france il a vingt mille
emplois en france
je vous dis pas que ça soit vertueux
ouais c'est un financier prédateur aussi
voir tout le monde j'en connais plein
mais vous voyez dire nous ne voulons
plus en france de quelqu'un qui a vingt
mille emplois c'est pas si on mesure qui
est qui et entre nous au passage à la
tête de toute la sidérurgie française
parce qu'on le lui a vendu et c'est pas
ce gouvernement actuel c'est le
gouvernement précédent et même hanté
précédent enfin moi je considère que
c'est contreproductif ne peut pas
s'exprimer de la sorte est donc cette
liberté de parole et de langage ça peut
être un repère le jour où les français
auront compris vu que là ya pas de
manoeuvre si on manoeuvre on est on est
fichu si on est en train d'essayer
d'organiser les choses pour trouver des
avantages des des privilèges des on est
fichu il faut que l'authenticité de
notre pensée de notre vision soit d'une
intégrité absolue
et là les français je crois un jour ou
l'autre vont s'apercevoir de deux choses
et j'en aurai fini là pour l'ouverture
de la discussion vont s'apercevoir de
deux choses premièrement que nous leur
avions dit la vérité
tout au long de ces années et que pas un
seul des diagnostics que nous avons que
nous avions faits ne se trouve démentie
par la réalité que tout ce qu'on leur
avait dit ça se produisait ligne à ligne
et deuxièmement
nous sommes la seule le seul courant
politique du pays prêts à travailler au
redressement sans nous soumettre aux uns
ou aux autres ou un travail au
redressement avec les uns et avec les
autres moi je crois que ils ne subissent
pas sera peu de mois avant que cette
attitude politique soit deviennent
singulière et donc attractive dans le
paysage politique français
voilà à peu près ce que j'ai en tête je
ne crois pas dissimuler les choses
robert va s'exprimer aussi à son tour et
puis vous autant que vous le autant que
vous le voudrez sachant seulement qu' on
avait promis de finir à 20 heures
précises en ira vers 20h15 mais guère au
delà
merci françois donc moi je voulais vous
dire deux choses la première c'est
peut-être que ça vous intéresse d'avoir
un avis sur le plan de la grèce enfin le
sauvetage de la grèce entendra parler
hier et l'avenir
ça c'est la première chose vis d'eux
d'autres petites choses sur la situation
économico politique française alors
l'histoire de la grèce c'est terrible ce
qui s'est passé hier
c'est pas un sauvetage de la grèce
auquel on a assisté hier
pas du tout c'est comment dire le
bourreau qui dessert un tout petit peu
l'étau pour que le torturer puisqu'en
même respirer et que ça puisse durer un
peu plus longtemps donc je suis au
regret de vous dire qu'on n'a pas du
tout sauver la situation de la grèce
hier on a aménagé la peine pour que
comment dire la grèce sur l'île un peu
plus longtemps alors je vais vous
expliquer ce qu'on a fait pour que vous
comprenez bien ce dont il s'agit en gros
le fn parce que c'est lui qui a pris le
pouvoir dans ce qu'on appelle la troïka
composée de la bce du fmi et la
commission européenne n'a été ni le fmi
a pris le pouvoir et a dit attendez nous
on a l'habitude de redresser les pays
dans lesquels les comptes ne vont pas du
tout et on sait très bien que si vous
laissez un plan dans lequel la tête qui
reste rembourser dans le pays est trop
élevé
ce pays n'arrivera jamais à s'en sortir
sur le raisonnement on est complètement
d'accord il n'ya pas d'incertitude à cet
égard et alors là avant le plan
d'avant-hier en 2020 le la convergence
des mesures qui étaient imposées à la
grèce devait arriver à ce que sa dette
publique atteigne 144 % du pib
cent quarante-quatre pour cent alors le
fmi a dit non cent quarante-quatre pour
cent c'est quand même trop donc on est
arrivé avec pierre hier ou avant-hier
c'était avant-hier j'ai essayé avancé
hier le temps passe vite on est arrivé à
l'it et alors ils sont arrivés à dire on
va arriver à 124 %
donc on va être à 124 % en 2020 voyez là
l'appel à faire quand c'est à dire que
bon alors comment on fait pour arriver à
124 % en 2020
pour faire simple on fait deux choses on
allonge la tête de la grèce qui va
passer de 15 ans à 30 ans voilà et
deuxième chose en baisse de 1% en baisse
de 1% les tons alors au passage on dit
aussi que c'est pas très moral que la
bce puisse s'enrichir sur le dos de
l'argent qu'elles prêtent à la grèce
donc on dit que la bce va restituer le
bénéfice qu'elle fera en ayant prêté de
l'argent dans ces conditions mais voilà
c'est à dire que on a utilisé vis-à-vis
de la grèce ce que beaucoup beaucoup de
banques d'affaires utilise lorsqu'il
s'agit de sauver une entreprise en
empêchant sa faillite et en essayant de
voir de quelle façon la production peut
quand même fonctionné et faire en sorte
que tout ce qui est dégagé 2
cette production a est directement aux
banquiers qui ont besoin de se
rembourser des dettes qui ont été faits
donc on est sur le zéro on est sur le
zéro on dit finalement si en est en
dessous du zéro la tête passe sous l'eau
et on pourra plus à respirer
donc on garde comment dire la tête sur
l'eau mais on n'a rien fait d' essentiel
c'est à dire que par rapport aux options
radicales
alors il ya plus aux options radicales
jeu pour les développer ici mais par
rapport aux options radicales
certaines surbottes certaines sont moins
bonnes on n'a pas vraiment tranché dans
le vif et d'ailleurs j'en veux comme
simple résultat que vous l'avez
peut-être vu aujourd'hui les bourses
n'ont pas du tout saluer ce qui a été
normalement serait dû être et une
envolée des bourses est pas du tout
c'est c'est tout simplement des bourses
qui sont plates et qui disent 'voilà et
alors les amis s'étaient financiers
disent quoi ils disent bon on est
peut-être tranquille pour six mois voilà
donc on est peut-être sans tranquille
pour les six mois qui viennent et puis
évidemment pour ce qui est de la
situation en particulier en italie et en
espagne et a évidemment strictement rien
qui a été fait et ça c'était pas du
ressort de la réunion d'hier donc
simplement pour vous dire que évidemment
je préfère que la situation soit comment
dire de telle manière que la grèce soit
pas en défaut demain matin et qu'on
puisse lui verser ses 40 milliards dead
qui sont tellement attendu mais en
réalité le courage n'a pas été au rendez
vous d'hier
ce qui était au rendez vous d'hier c'est
de trouver un compromis
malgré tout en faisant des concessions
ici ou là mais le courage réel pour
trouver une solution durable à la
situation de la grèce est enclenchée sur
une solution européenne n'a pas du tout
été au rendez vous alors si je parle par
ailleurs des échecs des réunions des
jours passés à la fois sur le budget
européen
et puis sur l'idée dans le conseil
européen d'avoir une perspective
différente de l'avenir de l'europe le
bain les choses ne sont évidemment pas
pas brillant voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire sur la question de la grèce je
sais pas si françois parent
on analyse absolument on n'en a pas
parlé absolument donc voilà donc je
trouve que alors je vous donne la parole
dans une seconde si vous voulez bien je
voulais juste parce que le temps passe
vite joué je veux dire ce que je pense
de la situation économique économico
politique française alors d'abord vous
avez vu qu'aujourd'hui je crois que
c'est le cd qui a sorti ses publie ses
prévisions donc toutes les organismes
les uns pour les autres centres
publication leurs prévisions donc 0 3%
pour les prochaines de vraiment une
grande convergence les 0 8%
bon il n'y a plus beaucoup de gens qui
croient bizarrement il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui crachent les
socialistes à dire que non mais je suis
c'est sincère enfin que j'ai eu
plusieurs fois l'occasion cours des
dernières semaines de parler avec celle
qu'on appelle l'étoile montante de
l'économie au ps qui est karine berger
qui est une collègue parce que elle elle
a comme moi et travailler dans dans les
couloirs de l'elysée pendant de
nombreuses années et elle est une
prévisionniste près sérieuse et elle y
croit c'est à dire que dans elle croit
que les 0 8% sont possibles elle me dit
françois hollande y croit aussi
il ya une sorte de puissance de cette
conviction alors est là pour l'anecdote
quand elle est devenue parlementaire
puisqu'elle est député depuis la
dernière élection l emmener chez elle le
modèle qu'elle a vu qu'elle fabriqué à
l'elysée pour les prévisions économiques
donc elle continue chez elle le soir à
faire tourner son modèle pour voir si ça
marche et si ses collègues de l'insee
une fois qu'elle les parties ne se sont
pas mis à faire des choses épouvantables
et donc elle continue à croire à cette
hypothèse de croissance qui en gros est
fondé sur une théorie mécanique des
cycles consistant à dire ben oui à la
rochelle vient le beau temps
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire la
théorie des cycles de soins sur
l'économie ça veut dire en gros à force
de ne pas investir à force de ne pas
investir les machines tombent en panne
et comme il faut quand même que les
machines fonctionnent donc dans les
usines et bien il ya bien un moment où
il faut que mécaniquement la
l'investissement reparte parce que voilà
donc ça c'est une des unes des pistes
juste ajouter anecdotes l'anecdote je
faisais une conférence participer à un
débat avec karine berger dimanche à
bordeaux à pessac sur les lendemains de
ceux de 68 et elle vient de publier un
livre avec une collègue qui s'appelle
les trente glorieuses sont devant nous
et moi j'ai quelques réticences à l'idée
que les trente glorieuses sont devant
nous d'abord parce que je crois que les
cycles de croissance ne sont pas
continue et que comme on dit dans le
monde boursier les arbres ne montent pas
jusqu'au ciel
il ya un moment de croissance des
sociétés comme des végétaux comme des
animaux et après il ya au contraire une
asymptote il ya un moment où ça croit
beaucoup moins parce que c'est déjà très
haut et donc karine berger elle a un
très grand optimisme volontariste sur
l'avenir moi j'ai plus de doute source
voilà alors si on croyait autorise des
cycles lors de l'arrivée la nouvelle
économie on aurait dû enchaîner un city
guide kondratiev de 25 ans de croissance
et vous voyez si vous mettez 25 ans
après l'arrivée de la nouvelle économie
en l'an 2000 on devrait être aujourd'hui
en soule un boom de cette croissance bon
alors je voulais juste vous dire un mot
sur tout cas moi ce que je ressens de
gouvernement économique de la france
aujourd'hui est de la position qu'ils
ont en tout cas la mienne et comment je
vois les choses comme l'a dit françois
tout à l'heure on a du mal à être en
désaccord avec les mesures qui sont
prises et qui vont dans le bon sens et
pour faire simple
beaucoup de mesures qui sont prises sont
fin justement parce qu'elles sont pas
pris c'est bien ce que je voulais dire
les horaires mesures qui sont annoncées
et pense souvent dans le bon sens la
vraie question est à mon avis la vraie
question pour nous enfin pour nous et
pour tous
moyens mais pour nous en tant qu
observateur privilégié de cette
situation c'est de savoir si dans les
trois mois dans les quatre mois il va
vraiment se passer quelque chose ou pas
parce que pour l'instant il ne se passe
rien
c'est à dire que les annonces ce film là
mais il ne se passe rien la machine
n'est pas n'est pas mobilisée pour faire
en sorte qu'il se passe quelque chose et
là ça va être extrêmement difficile
effectivement s'il ne se passait rien et
puis si vous me permettez juste un
commentaire sur la question de florange
et de monsieur montebourg et de monsieur
vital d'abord on a peut-être vu
qu'aujourd'hui le maire de londres a
fait de l'humour en disant bas puisque
le gouvernement français veut mettre à
la porte mittal qu'ils viennent
massivement à londres en angleterre nous
on l'attend je vous rappelle juste que
c'est boris johnson le maire de dornes
café qui a dit ça le monsieur mittal
c'est la deuxième fortune britannique
faut quand même faut quand même le
savoir
oui et quand il marie sa fille je crois
que ça coûte 55 millions de livres
mais voilà mais d'empêcher mittal est la
deuxième de deuxième fortune britannique
j'espère qu'ils se paient l'eau depuis
ce que je crois que ce qui me gêne ce
qui me gêne dans la décision qui a été
prise c'est pas comment dire cette
décision j'ai entendu ce matin françois
face à jean michel aphatie sur rtl qui
disait est évidemment ce ne peut-être
que l'on peut être que d'accord avec ça
qui consistait à dire enfin encore
faut-il qu à florange ceux capables de
fabriquer des aciers pour lesquels il ya
une demande s'il s'agit pas de
rencontrer une demande ça ne sert pas à
grand chose
mais au-delà de ça j'ai pas été
tellement va j'ai été gêné évidemment
par les propos de montebourg consistant
à dire on ne veut plus de deux buts elle
en france mais j'ai aussi été gêné par
le vocabulaire utilisée qui a consisté à
laisser croire aux peuples français et
en particulier à celui qui est dans la
misère et aux chiffres du chômage au
départ tout à l'heure on allait pouvoir
refaire des nationalisations
et ça m'a terriblement comment dire
inquiété et je ne sais pas si vous avez
entendu ce matin dans les auditeurs qui
ont la parole dans les différentes
émissions de radio je entendu comment
dire un auditeur qui disait sur une
radio
mais alors si on est capable de
renationaliser florange valeur il
faudrait renationaliser dans ma cédantes
chez moi mon entreprise qui va et c'est
etc etc
et évidemment évidemment et c'est là où
on voit quelque chose que je trouve très
difficile dans la période politique que
nous vivons et en particulier avec les
socialistes au pouvoir c'est que ce set
cet aggiornamento se battent de desberg
que l'on peut espérer
on n'est jamais complètement sûr qu'il
ira jusqu'au bout il ya deux sortes de
tentations régressive de revenir en
arrière une façon que je trouve qu'à
françois hollande de la faire à la
mitterrand mais je sais pas si
mitterrand le ferai comme ça aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs parce que c'est mitterrand
c'était il ya trente ans de donner un
sentiment d'avoir un coup vers une sorte
d'âge d'or à bento puis un coup qui
laisse entendre que l'on peut croire
encore aux vieilles ou vieux habits ceux
qui sont totalement totalement hors
d'usagé que totalement dépassées et
c'est ça qui m'inquiète c'est que d'un
côté donc il ya des mesures qui vont
dans le bon sens en terme d'annoncés
mais dont on attend la concrétisation et
jeu je souhaite en ce qui me concerne
que ces concrétisations se fasse je
souhaite que la paix pays fassent du bon
travail
donc la bpi ne sera pas déconcentré
réellement dans sa structuration global
on mettra deux ans que pour
l'investissement
oui la banque publique -
l'investissement on mettra deux
représentants des régions
un petit peu j'avais l'impression un peu
en petits chevaux conseil
d'administration parce que je ne crois
pas vraiment que ces deux membres des
régions joueront un rôle absolument
centrale alors on nous a annoncé que 90%
c'est le président lui-même qui l'a dit
dans sa conférence de presse
90% des décisions seront prises le plus
près possible du terrain j'attends c'est
ça qu'il faut que nous voyons est en
phase donc par rapport à cette situation
avec monsieur mittal
cette façon de caresser des rudes
nostalgie
situation du passé et puis d'ailleurs si
ça marche ça donnera encore plus la
possibilité à certains de dire mais faut
le faire ailleurs
moi j'aurais préféré qu'on utilise
d'autres mots quand comment dire quand
les ministres sont capables de venir de
dire qu'il faut pas parler d'austérité
parce que c'est un gros bobo j'aurais
aimé qu'ils utilisent d'autres mots que
des mots qui sont une nationalisation
qui soit contrôle public
voilà j'aurais aimé que ce soit des mots
qui laisse rendent possible cette idée
parce que si c'est finalement si c'est
absolument une bonne chose puisque
monsieur mittal dans le fond comme vous
l'avez dit à juste titre sa financiers
il veut pas relancer
florent je ne veux pas du tout mais bon
s'il empoche comment dire quelque chose
qu'ils indemnisent il n'est pas contre
donc je ne fais pas confiance à monsieur
mittal pour être porteurs d'un projet
industriel effectifs sur les sites de
florange
je me fais plus confiance à cet égard et
j'ai l'impression vous non plus quand
vous dites que c'est un financier donc
c'est pas sur son évaluation à lui qu'il
n'est pas possible de faire quelque
chose à florange le jama puis en
revanche si on peut faire quelque chose
et bien tant mieux mais qu'on la paye qu
on l'habille autrement qu'on la baisse
parce que je pense et celles qui sont au
dessus alors une ruche dessus et puis il
ya quelques jours mais en même temps que
nos principes mais donc en tout cas
qu'on la vie autrement qu on appelle ça
autrement qu'on ne fasse pas qu'on ne
ris pas comment dire des espoirs qui
sont des espoirs qui sont forcément avec
des déceptions considérable derrière et
puis qu'on en arrive alors qu'on les
attendait patiemment à des mesures
concrètes dans les prochaines semaines
c'est vraiment ça notre rendez-vous et
et nous serons vigilants en tout cas sur
cette question en tout cas vous voyez
notre liberté de penser et un atout pour
l'instant c'est pas encore
massif mais c'est un atout très
important de pouvoir dire oui et non et
attention c'est moi je considère que la
politique française elle devrait être
entre des forces qui ont 7
cette objectivité de regarder les choses
en tout cas ne il me semble que ça nous
singularise beaucoup dans le dans le
monde politique français
alors à vous la parole pendant les 20
minutes aux 25 minutes qui reste d'un
service chacun voilà je voudrais juste
revenir cher françois sur la période ce
matin je dirais plutôt la discussion
d'ailleurs avec jean michel aphatie qui
prouve pas d'appartement placé ville et
apprécier beaucoup au réveil
c'était très à l'aise j'aurais revenir
sur quelque chose
robert et je ne suis pas d'accord pour
ce qui est de me tanne du laxisme de la
joaillière il se trouve que mon épouse
est indienne que j'ai fait un mariage
indien que ma famille et de cette
famille là et indiennes que ce sont tous
des industriels échangés sur les
cliniques sont des gens qui sont les
affaires ce sont des gens qui dans leurs
esprits n'ont rien contre les autres il
faut être bien clair c'est pas un ennemi
c'est pas quelqu'un qui dans son esprit
peut-être un aimé et ce n'est pas un
financier à l'anglo-saxonne c'est à dire
la finance pour la finance s'il peut
faire des affaires en rendant service
aux pays dans lequel il fait ses
affaires il reculera et le prendre de
cette façon aussi violente aussi boutal
je dirais presque aussi vulgaire s'était
il va pas apprécier
franchement donc donc voilà je pense que
françois hollande aura une fin de
recevoir et
il ya quelque chose qui est d'autant
plus ridicule dans cette histoire là
c'est que mon horreur ne pas du tout se
rendre compte que c'est une filière
s'est pas seulement florange c'est une
filière que la chaîne a froide florent
je fais partie d'une filière
industrielle et que brutal c'est une
condition de même de survie de cette
filière là on touche pas à la chaîne à
froid sinon un ensemble de choses vont
tomber
c'est comme des dominos la marche la
deuxième chose surtout je reproche à
notre pays une maladie terrible c'est de
faire l'autruche
parce que là on parle de florange il n'y
a pas que ça il ya le raffinage le
raffinage en france va s'écrouler
faut pas croire qu'il va pas s'écrouler
alors on essaye de sauver petit couronne
mais c'est un leurre solu les autres
raffineries vont tomber les unes
derrière les autres et pas seulement en
france
qu'est ce qu'on va faire or à
nationaliser la fionie aussi c'est
complètement ridicule
le fait est que notre pays ne fait pas
refusent de faire le diagnostic de son
avenir de la transition énergétique en
particulier de tous les énormes efforts
qu'il faut faire et à cause de ce refus
la et bien nous ne voyons pas ce qui va
se passer nous laissons à croire
accepter les vosges en nous laissant
croire qu'on va pouvoir les sauver or ce
n'est pas vrai on ne va pas du tout les
sauver de je pense que françois vous
avez dit attention peut d'ailleurs je
pense qu'effectivement nous appartient à
nous en dehors de la critique et des
conseils sur le la gouvernance de
rappeler aussi que nous avons un devoir
de diagnostic sur l'avenir bien sûr
d'ailleurs pour aller dans votre sens ce
matin
le type de la cgt qui était interviewé
sait plus si c'était après moi ou avant
moi que j'ai entendu il disait eh bien
il faut pas s'arrêter là il faut
nationaliser la totalité de la
sidérurgie en france on disait excuse
moi mais je suis pas d'accord avec toi
sur le premier point
alors je voudrais juste dire pourquoi
d'abord j'ai eu un certain nombre
d'articles sur monsieur mittal et dans
ses articles
on dit qu'en gros monsieur mittal adore
deux choses fondamentales dans la vie
c'est sa famille et l'argent donc très
bien on a le droit d'aimer l'argent et
d'aimer sa famille c'est pas du tout se
sait bien que deux mais l'argent tout se
voit là c'est pour ça qu'on dépense 55
millions de sterling quand on fait le
canton marie sa fille mais je crois
profondément que monsieur mittal
parce que il est britannique et
d'origine indienne
je croque monsieur mittal ne porte pas
dans ses objectifs personnels
la reconstruction de notre pays de la
france et qu'on ne peut pas qu'on ne
peut pas comment ils vont vouloir mais
il faut qu'on l'intègre nous et il faut
donc qu'à partir du moment où nous
sommes dans une hypothèse justement de
vouloir reconstruire notre pays et c'est
lié à ce que nous appelions le produire
en france pendant la campagne
présidentielle et c'est lié aussi au
fait que c'est bien l'illustration qu'on
ne peut pas avoir un capitalisme en
france qui seront organisées sur une
sorte de monopoly de grands groupes et
de très très grande entreprise qui
oublient ce que les allemands ont su
faire c'est à dire un réseau un maillage
d'entreprises de taille intermédiaire de
pme parce que ces entreprises là parce
que quand on est un patron d'une pme
dans un lander en allemagne
eh bien je suis désolé mais et c'est
bien eh bien on se on s'intéresse à
destiner des personnes qui vivent dans
ce land heures et en particulier des
personnes qui y travaillent et monsieur
mittal g strictement rien contre lui
mais cette espèce de mécano que l'on a
fabriqué et bien qui est typiquement une
déconstruction de la globalisation
d'aujourd'hui et demain ça risque de se
produire exactement de la même façon
avec y compris des groupes comme
deux types de groupes ça aboutit à ce
type de résultat donc aucune agressivité
contre monsieur vital mais en même temps
nous aboutissons aux résultats que
quelque part nous avons organisé
collectivement par cette façon de ne pas
comprendre la réalité et les germes de
nos problèmes et d'avoir laissé
s'installer ce type de capitalisme qui
pour moi pose vraiment un grand problème
non seulement moral
mais un problème politique est un
problème pour l'avenir et bien robert
moi je suis pas tout à fait je ne suis
pas tout à fait de cet avis je pense que
le problème est beaucoup plus simple que
ça je pense que le groupe de monsieur
mittal est endetté de 24 milliards
d'euros et que devant le sait au fond
comme la france devant la menace de deux
sets de 7 de semur financier qui va si
les banques de s'écrouler
eh bien ils coupent dans tout ce qui
n'est pas rentable c'est la situation du
groupe mittal qui crée la situation
c'est pas son absence de patriotisme
n'est même pas le côté financier
c'est l' équilibre qui est désormais
créer dans le bilan de ce déséquilibre
qui est créé dans le bilan de ce groupe
pourquoi parce que la consommation
d'acier s'est effondré sur les derniers
les deux dernières années et que les
pays chine had en développement à qui
nous vendions d acier de haute valeur
ajoutée se sont mis à produire non il a
dû mettre un peu de sou de côté on va
aller au fond de la salle si vous voulez
et une voix féminine
voilà c'est à quelques fois des
avantages unis bonjour je voulais réagir
au discours de robert rochefort quand il
a parlé de karine berger et de là sa
théorie des cycles ou en fait quand les
machines on vieillit on les remplace
simplement est ce qu'on observe de plus
en plus c'est que les investissements
sur les machines se font plus en france
ni même en europe pratiquement et se
font dans les pays émergents et il ya
une donc un article dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui qui parlait de de l'avenir
des jeunes diplômés et qu'en fait les
jeunes ingénieurs occidentaux donc
européens et américains seraient de plus
en plus amenés à s'expatrier pour faire
de 10 ans de recherche développement et
de la production dans les pays émergents
et ça je trouve que c'est catastrophique
mais on peut espérer que c'est passager
ce que moi je crois alors ça c'est comme
on disait en latin credo khouya absurde
hommage
je crois j'ai pas de raison rationnelle
de le dire mais c'est une
c'est une intuition ou en tout cas un
espoir
moi je crois qu'on va découvrir
évidemment qu'il y a aussi beaucoup de
désavantages à être loin expatriés y
compris pour le développement des
process pour et je suis frappé vous
savez que je vis juste à côté de
plusieurs grandes très grandes
entreprises industrielles aéronautiques
su frappé de voir que l'idée des
relocalisations et quand même désormais
en partie dans l'air du temps
d'abord parce que les expatriés ça coûte
cher
ensuite parce que le mode de vie dans
ces sociétés
dès l'instant qu'on avance un peu dans
la vie devient plus aléatoire plus enfin
moi j'ai c'est que les enfants
grandissent et qu'on voudrait qu'il soit
français et qu'on voudrait qu'ils
lisaient l'éducation nationale gratuite
parce que c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose de faire des études supérieures en
france où où ça voilà où ça ne coûte
rien et même avec un coup de pot dans
certaines très grande école vous vous
êtes payés pour faire les études c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose que
d'avoir à débourser 40 mille dollars par
an pour se payer une université de bon
niveau et donc je moi je crois que que
notre
notre pays peut être attractif pour peu
que ils apparaissent que dans ce pays on
soutient les activités dont on parle on
soutient les entreprises on soutient les
créateurs ision leur place ils sont
reconnus leur donne des légions
d'honneur s'il en a envie il ya des gens
qui aiment ça bon tout cas moi moi ma
boutonnière et propre monsieur est donc
c'est une plaisanterie qu'on faisait
autrefois dans les chais les 68 ans et
donc et donc il faut les signes de
reconnaissance et il faut orienter c'est
ce qui manque le plus aujourd'hui au
fond je dis ce que tu as dit à ma
manière et ce que nous pensons qu est ce
qui manque
il manque la mobilisation générale de la
nation des forces vives autour d'un
projet national
il manque que le le président de la
république parce que c'est son boulot
organise les choses de manière
consciente que le pays poussent que
toutes les forces du pays vont pousser
dans le même sens et c'est pas du tout
ce qu'on s'en est précisément les
affaires montebourg ces mots utilisés
l'accent qui est mis
c'est un contre messages sur cette auto
de cette idée et qui est tout à fait
entendu à l'extérieur voix masculine où
vous voulez oui je vais juste un
complément à ta question notre pays
quand on le regarde si on le regarde en
faisant fi des données historiques et
culturelles récente et qu'on le regarde
comme ça comme un aplat il devrait être
un pays
qui avec une capacité de production une
croissance extraordinaire
nous avons énormément d'atouts nous
avons géographique est extraordinaire
nous avons des infrastructures
absolument considérable nous avons une
énergie qui coûte absolument pas cher
pour l'instant en tout cas je dis pas
que enfin en tout cas c'est un atout
d'aujourd'hui je dis pas que bon et nous
avons une démographie c'est à dire que
la démographie française est un atout
que peu de pays autour de nous
l'allemagne a une démographie
catastrophique
l'italie et l'espagne sont en train
d'avoir des démographies absolument
catastrophique même la pologne
démographique est en train de s'inverser
la france a une démographie
extraordinaire cette démographie qui
fait d'ailleurs que dans 20 ans nous
aurons un peu près la même population a
priori que l'allemagne seront rattrapés
comment dire le retard nous aurons par
rapport à l'allemagne mais en même temps
cette chance démographique on lagache et
on lagache pourquoi parce que
effectivement le fait que nous ayons des
jeunes que nous reproduisions nos
générations et donc notre population
progresse parce qu'on vit de plus en
plus vieux en n'offrant pas de débouchés
à ses jeunes on gâche
l'atout principal que nous avons et moi
je ne sais pas si les jeunes iront à
l'autre bout du monde
je pense qu'ils seront pas obligés de
tout le monde parce que je pense que
c'est nos amis allemands qui vont
prendre nos jeunes si d'une certaine
façon nous ne leur proposons pas des
emplois rémunérés qui soient des eaux
non mais ça va s'accélérer ça va
s'accélérer mais oui mais le l'enjeu
comment dire l'enjeu de la croissance
allemande
l'enjeu de la croissance allemande est
tellement important pour eux que voilà
donc donc nous avons un devoir de faire
en sorte que comment dire ce talent ou
cette chance ou 7 vraiment cet atout
considérable qui est qui qui hélas nous
ne le cachons pas et nous ne
transformions pas en inconvénient en
poids lourds en charge en charge sociale
en charge financière en charge de
désespérance et donc c'est vraiment une
question tout à fait fondamental ça
devrait nous devrions considérer que
parce que nous avons cette chance
nous avons encore plus le 2
de réussir les intervenants parce qu il
est 20h15 que nous prenons l'habitude de
faire j'ai pris les vitraux qui qui a
pris le micro c'est moi qui ai pris une
micro de manière non démocratique
un vrai démocrate
oui il ya un élément très important de
mon avis une fracture dont vous n'avez
pas parlé tout à l'heure c'est la
fracture entre les citoyens et la
politique et la classe politique
aujourd'hui je trouve et nous l'avons
rencontré lors des élections
législatives
c'est que la classe politique en tant
que tel française n'est plus du tout
crédible pour des raisons que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure à savoir des
politiques blanc bonnet ou bonnet blanc
la droite ou la gauche c'est le même
programme
là ce qui peut donc avantagés les
extrêmes qu'elles soient de droite ou de
gauche c'est aussi la
professionnalisation de la classe
politique
on va attendre nous voyons toujours les
mêmes sur les plateaux télé et donc du
coup c'est dur ce n'est plus une guerre
de un débat d'idées mais c'est un débat
de chefs pour avoir le pouvoir pour
asseoir son pouvoir
l'épisode de l'ump est assez flagrant à
ce niveau là alors si je parle fracture
entre la classe politique et les
français c'est que si on veut déjà gagné
de nouvelles élections afin de gagner
des élections
si on veut mobiliser des français un
projet quel qu'il soit projet salvateur
ou la france encore faut-il
rand du crédit à la place poétique aux
hommes politiques
et pour ça il me semble nécessaire de
faire un big bang sociétal où un big
bang politique sur les politiques en
tant que tel le non cumul
à savoir deux ans afin de mandats pas
plus d'autres d'autres de enfin d'autres
propositions que je n'ai pas en tête
mais ça ça me semble le bea bas d'un
nouveau contrat social entre les
français et la classe politique pour
pouvoir donner de la crédibilité est
absolument et c'est pourquoi j'avais
proposé c'est pourquoi j'ai proposé le
référendum de moralisation de la vie
publique pour faire non pas un big bang
mais un choc pour que les gens aient le
sentiment que après avant c'était pas la
même chose
j'entends dire je n'ose pas penser que
c'est vrai mais j'entends dire que les
socialistes sont en train de dire on va
faire les cumuls des mandats mais pour
et bien je vous jure que s'ils font ça
ils sont décrédibilisés à jamais en
quelques heures
non pas que l'on puisse pas discuter du
cumul des mandats on aurait pu
simplement quand tout un un courant
civique citoyen s'est formé autour de
cette idée qui est en effet une idée de
moralisation de on va faire accéder de
nouvelles filles visage de nouveaux
visages de nouvelles générations enfin
c'est compliqué la sphère des nouvelles
générations parce que comme la vie
humaine s'allonge
ben les politiques qui sont des humains
comme les autres enfin en tout étaient
physiologiquement ils sont et humain
comme les autres et donc
eux aussi sont sont jeunes plus
longtemps mais c'est absolument exact
que il faut faire apparaître de nouveaux
visages c'est pourquoi proportionnelle
c'est très important
moi je n'hésite pas à dire j'ai combattu
leurs idées toute ma vie mais je veux il
faut qu'il y ait de l'extrême droite à
l'assemblée nationale et de l'extrême
gauche à l'assemblée nationale
un nom
il faut ça eh bien on les combattra la
tribune et y aura des mouvements
d'opinion et tout ce qu'on veut mais au
moins les discours à la tribune seront
plus l'eau tiède qu'on a tout le temps
qu'ils s'intéressent aux discours un
tribune de l'assemblée
personne et pourquoi pas ce que parce
que il n'ya aucune émotion dans tout ça
vous savez que le type de la majorité
qui monte à la tribune
c'est pour dire le gouvernement est
formidable et que le type de
l'opposition qui monte à la tribune
c'est pour dire le gouvernement est nul
et ça applaudit à gauche au premier et
ça applaudit à droite au deuxième il
n'ya jamais la moindre originalité vie
style panache humour aérienne tout ça
comment comment vous est il ya 577
personnes plus d'hommes que de femmes et
bien sûr qu'ils jouent à cette espèce de
théâtre d'ombrés et ça coûte les yeux de
la tête et donc bien sûr qu' il fallait
faire ce que vous dites big band en tout
cas ce changement ce renversement au
sens étymologique cette révolution pour
qu'on ait le sentiment que oui enfin
c'est pas tout à fait comme avant et
c'était très facile
je crains qu'on aura de cette chance
dieu sait pourtant que jospin c'est
timide et ça passe à côté de bien des
choses mais au moins font ouvrir ça et
je n'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi si
j'arrive à comprendre parce que quand on
a des deux puissants soutiens dans les
assemblées des assemblées elles veulent
rester comme elles sont et quand les
gens sont en même temps élus locaux et
dans les assemblées ils veulent rester
comme ils sont et vous avez pas envie de
faire de la peine à vos habits
mais les cas mais c'est pas que l'écart
se creuse tout ce dont nous parlons là
qui est programmatique qui est de style
qui est de disputer de haines recuites
ça fait qu'il n'y a plus de lien le
cordon par quoi passe la confiance est
brisée mais les gens n'écoutent même
plus faut voir ça les amuse et trois
jours l'ump
mais au bout de trois jours il disait il
en vient à s'en c'est pour eux
c'est un autre monde sait c'est
d'ailleurs des manières de parler qui
sont plus enfin il n'y a plus rien de
tout ça c'est des jeux qui ne le que
dans lesquels ils se reconnaissent plus
eh bien il nous à part il nous
appartient de faire que de nouveau un
jour ici reconnaissent telle est notre
mission
il éviterait qui remercia tous